academia we'd like to think of it as the
key to the world of knowledge with the
key masters being the best among us
unfortunately what we know as the world
of higher education has become uh a bit
of a fars
and by bit i mean entirely enter
the riveting academic world of
fat pride
bursting at the scenes with self-love
acceptance and
well just bursting at the seams it turns
out that there is an entire academic
discipline known as fat studies home to
peer-reviewed think pieces such as
overcoming fear of fat and queering fat
embodiment
yes this is actually being taught by
professors at some of the world's most
prestigious institutions there's even an
annual fat studies conference at massey
university where all the brave and
beautiful postgrads can submit their
essays and present them in their
fun-sized safe space so let's meet a few
of my soon-to-be peer-reviewed
colleagues our fat licious keynotes
esther rothbloom and sonia renee taylor
have given us amazing talks about fat
histories our fat present and what our
fat futures might hold how does fat
blackness embody the future i am an
artist i'm an activist i'm a serious
macaroni and cheese maker i'm black i'm
queer i'm fast i'm neuro-divergent and
awkwardly class mobile
quote
i'm a fat water jogger myself and every
time i go to the swimming pool i can see
what people are thinking about my
experience and sadness is always trying
to be contained there's always you know
the world is always trying to contain
fatness the world is always trying to
wrangle fatness you need to see that
bodies take up space and allow them to
move the way that people fat body small
and i've called for a new fat ethics
acknowledging the role science has
played in the oppression of fat people
white men now small white men who in
many ways have been the early scholars
in this area interesting to see
um small white men studying large women
mostly so what you're looking at on the
left hand is sergey bartman also known
as the hot and hot venus
she was a
cosa woman
um from africa and
sold to circuses and by the time you get
to kim kardashian and 2014
that is the aesthetic now i decided to
write and submit my very own fat studies
paper for presentation and with the help
of my brilliant researcher i wrote an
entire essay titled embracing fatness as
self-care in the era of trump i then
submitted the abstract to the conference
and uh oh did i say that i wrote the
essay i meant to say it was submitted by
c matheson a wonderful and totally
academically legitimate genderqueer fat
pride activist all right turn me into c
mathilson
[Music]
creating an identity
[Music]
[Music]
now unfortunately due to kovid the
in-person conference
was canceled and the floorboards thanked
us luckily for miss matheson there was
still a virtual conference and that's
great news because z's abstract was
actually accepted by the chairwoman dr
cat pause a self-described fat study
scholar and just like that
c matheson was scheduled to speak
alongside these intellectual titans
so grab your popcorn quadruple buttered
and let's start the show
ready
oops
[Music]
hello i am c matheson i am an activist
based out of austin texas uh
specifically working with the non-binary
and fat community
to help increase presence of
intersectional and non-binary people
with such events in austin as a women's
march march for our lives most recently
the global climate strikes my preferred
pronouns are
she and her and my paper embracing
fatness as self-care in the era of
donald trump
is something i'm thrilled to be
presenting and has been accepted here at
the new zealand fat studies uh
conference 2020 because of our current
leaders bigotry fatness
i will argue acts as a distancing
mechanism from the president
as well as his supporters producing both
physical and ideological space that can
insulate the individual from um
intolerant bigoted or violent ideology
so first off there is a i'd like to
issue a content warning regarding
some fat phobia discussed in this next
portion
it's widely acknowledged of course that
the 2016 election of president donald
trump was evident of america's
some would argue underlying racist
xenophobic homophobic and transphobic
attitudes i would argue that it was
always there not so underlying it just
took 2016 for more people to realize it
if we can say that's a silver lining
for lack of a better word at all uh
trump's fat phobia has received
relatively little attention
in comparison trump regularly engages in
attacks on fat bodies individuals trump
is known to target women with his
attacks referring to women
as having faces that are
quote fat
um or ugly and trump's fat phobia even
reaches into the united states
international relations in his dealing
with north korean leader kim jong-un
trump referred to the leader uh as
quote short and fat
atlantic writer best levin responded to
trump's devaluation of fat bodies
not by call not by calling out president
trump's bigotry um for which no one
would have found fault which is what's
very upsetting but by engaging in
further
degradation of fatness noting that
president trump was was quote
definitionally obese and quote could
share clothes
with jabba the hutt when it comes to
trump's fat phobia often the current
progressive left
they resort to fighting fire with fire
using fat phobia in their own critiques
and rebuttals biden himself uh the
current democratic candidate
recently lashed out at a campaign event
calling an attendee fat and challenging
him to an exercise program most notably
push-ups individuals have noticed an
increased need for self-care in the era
of trump and this context necessitates
in my opinion a reclaiming of
of fatness in the era of trump
and what follows is an ethnography of my
attempts at affirming
um of affirming my own
body as an act sorry about that i'll
keep it's going really well here um my
own body as an act of self-care
affirming it i will i will um present
that as an act of self-care uh many
who do so may not even realize it um
take this quotation from the new york
times about self-care let me read this
for a moment
um
or let's say that your health has dipped
in that case self-care for you might
focus on building a workout routine
now here we see the linking of health
with working out
is clearly an example of anti-fat bias
or
the general discussion of self-care
often revolves around the concept of
space
individuals express a need for
for some space um
persons are said to be
in a good or bad headspace uh the
publication mashable even recently
highlighted the efforts of astronauts to
practice self-care in outer space
space is an important element of
self-care
and one tool for creating both
ideological and physical space is
fatness when i was younger on several
occasions i was touched
um or fondled sexually um and on on some
of these occasions it was done without
my permission so in college and grad
school however um i
gained a significant amount of weight at
first i will say i was driven to shane
by my friends and family they would say
things like you need to take you need to
take better care of yourself um and at
this point to be clear i did not yet
identify as fat
one day uh however all that changed um i
was uh fueling my vehicle at a nearby
gas station and as i was collecting my
receipt
um a man reached out
and tried to touch me
okay
sexually
and um i did i realized i had a
realization that i i wasn't worried now
why was i not worried um because i
understood that in that moment because
of
what at this point i was referring to as
my freshman pounds my new found fat this
stranger regardless of his determination
was very would have far greater
difficulty in grabbing my genitalia
without my consent um
and that was where i began to explore
the idea that fatness
can be self-care
from that point on i actively chose to i
identified as fat and i realized that
i realized that um once i was already
being perceived as fat by others
i protected myself from
the base or impulses of toxic
masculinity
and rape culture fatness embracing a fat
identity ensuring one is always uh
already perceived to be a fat
a fat individual subject these actions
become performative acts of resistance
especially in this tumultuous time as
deaths from from covet 19
surge over 100 000
um of course uh
my sympathies and i can't even i can't
even imagine go out to anyone affected
by this pandemic um but more than ever
space is critical
it's
the importance of space cannot be
overstated
space is one i'm sorry
space often we see now is a matter of
life and death
uh recently i was uh picturing my
favorite um local grocer and there i saw
a man of course we've all seen this
person without a mask
and even though this man decided not to
protect others
or myself
by wearing a mask
he had taken the time
to put on his make america great again
cap
[Music]
okay
but i wasn't worried
and i knew that largely because of my
fat
i was guaranteed at least a certain
amount of space you may believe
wrongly as many people do that fat is a
threat to your life
but i would argue that in many ways it
may save your life
i used to feel guilty about eating
certain foods or drinking certain soft
drinks um
but i don't i don't anymore every scoop
of ben jerry's
um
or whatever whatever your preferred food
may be
[Music]
i would like to see it restructured and
it should be
seen as an act of resistance
not only against homophobia but against
fat phobia
as the waist size for example of my
pants increases in many ways so does my
power and so does yours and i want you
to
understand that i want all people to
understand that and believe that
so i would like to um summarize this by
saying that
personal
fatness is a visible statement
okay what i mean by that
it says
i do not conform
i do not submit
i decide what i do with my body and no
one else not you
not a medical professional and certainly
not donald j trump
it is a visible statement that says keep
your distance
i am not one of you
i don't have to be one of you arbitrary
standards of so-called health
do not rule me they do not rule over me
i will not participate
in your
bullying
as a society i am an individual
i am here
and i am resisting
[Music]
fat is here
and it is not silent
um
thank you again i am c matheson uh and i
very much appreciate you giving me the
time to present this and look forward to
answering your questions
of course this was all pure lunacy and i
was certain that the jig was up and that
it would be curtains for c matheson in
the world of academia after all these
ideas aren't grounded in any scientific
literature data or even
reality and it was clearly a goof so
imagine my surprise when this absolute
joke was not only accepted to a
prestigious academic conference
but c matheson was met with rave reviews
dr esther rothblum phd
even reached out to see matheson after
the conference to peer review a paper on
you guessed it fat studies look ma i'm
an authoritative source
the problem isn't just that lunatic
ideas like fat pride are accepted and
even peer-reviewed at institutions as
cleverly designed ruses to boost
scholarly book sales but the problem of
education doesn't exist
in a bubble think about it for a second
what happens to the students
what happens when they grow up
and become lawyers doctors or god forbid
teachers themselves today's ivory tower
quackery is tomorrow's gospel truth
crazy ideas like gender fluidity endless
pronouns fat pride they were all created
the same way and became ingrained into
our authoritative sources this isn't
anything new the insanity of higher
education has been influencing culture
for decades in the late 1980s you had
the birth of queer studies with an
academic conference at yale the
conference grew and by the 1990s had
hundreds attending and presenting fast
forward now 40 years later we have
prestigious academics preaching about
the wonders of gender fluidity and
actually identifying as two-spirited
it's not just that these ideas are
insane
it's that they are unfounded they're
unverified and most of all untrue which
makes them seriously harmful when
doctors
are being pressured by academics to
praise the beautiful bravery of their
350 pound land whale patients lives will
be lost life expectancy will be traded
to preserve the fragile egos and
financial interests of academic elites
but that doesn't matter right as long as
people like dr kat pazae feel free to be
themselves in all their super-sized
glory so to all you beautiful woolly
mammoths raise your twinkie the experts
are on your side
oh my god becky look at her butt what i
find fascinating and um i think is
represented in this quote right here um
is the collapsing
of fatness and blackness when fatness
merges with blackness
it stops trying to sub it stops trying
to
um
put the put the fat body under control
and it moves very quickly to
must be annihilated
hey did you like this video don't care
hit the notification bell share it with
someone because
you know what look
some people add value to society
and then there's you and you can start
by at least sharing this you don't have
to create the value but you can spread
the value uh and look at look at you
go to crowdershop.com right dave look at
this person uh he's garbage look at you
and now look at us look at us
z is garbage by the way
because that's the most offensive thing
we've said
subscribe